most resilient parasite is not a
bacteria it's not a virus it is a
thought and it shapes everything he is
an expert on the topic of happiness
google made him the head of google x
the return of
i know people will hate me when i say
this dating isn't entirely an economics
problem when you don't know what you're
looking for then you're advertising
wrong how do you find out what you're
looking for though if you want to find
love it's very straightforward
at the the last line in your book you
say please find the compassion in your
heart to want happiness for my wonderful
son ali why did you bring that up we
were having
an easy conversation
i wrote sulfur happy at a time where ali
had just left our world and he helped me
really really figure things out we think
that this brain is supposed to be there
to make us successful your brain is
supposed to make you happy i feel that
the top three reasons for unhappiness in
the world are
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
the return
of mo gowda oh man
no pressure
i mean i don't really know what to say
so our first conversation as you'll know
as i've said many times to my audience
is still to this date my favorite
podcast episode of all time for so many
reasons
it had everything that i've ever wanted
from a conversation it had the
personal story
delivered in a way with immense honesty
and vulnerability and wisdom
i learned so much from that conversation
and of all the conversations i've had
whenever i'm asked wherever i go i say
that that conversation is the
conversation that's had the most
profound impact on the real fundamentals
of my life than any other
the words that you said then still show
up at pivotal moments in my life when
i'm feeling a certain way or i'm letting
something get the best of me and it's
really really liberated
me of so many things so when i heard you
were back in london
i had to
have another conversation with you
it's an honor honestly thanks for asking
i have to ask since we spoke what's
changed in your life
and how does your life look
now
ah
ever changing uh interestingly i'm on
you know in
2020 was my year of silence and space
2021 was my year of flow
and then at the beginning of 2022 i
asked myself what will this year be
about i take a theme for every year
because it's sort of an interesting way
to
guide your life in terms of where you
want to go i don't like targets it's too
businessy when you come when it comes to
your own connection to yourself
and 2022 i decided it will also be a
year of flow but i called it the year of
joy inflow which is really interesting
so so to me
believe it or not as i worked through
the years on empowering more of my
feminine side and you know creativity uh
paradoxical thinking flow all of those
sometimes appearingly not so disciplined
uh traits are are hyper feminine and
they're very valuable in terms of
enjoying life but also seeing the full
reality of life if you want
i did very well in 2020 with my approach
to flow i went wherever life wanted me
to go but i was still
the same mo you know very targeted very
focused very able to
get the maximum out of everything
around that of course there has been
a lot of interesting
repercussions of our conversation that
basically allowed me to
write more to
connect more i tend to be very personal
when it comes to my presence on social
media so got in touch with so many
wonderful people and i think that's
created waves of flow if you want in my
life
whereby uh by and by end of april i
packed everything up that i had in dubai
put it in a tiny little storage space
i've always been a minimalist anyway so
it wasn't much and now i have no idea
where i'm going from here
completely inflow
what does that mean you have no idea
where you're going from here
i'm in london because of my book
publication
until end of the month and then
we'll find out
there's something quite curious about
that because i think we tend to believe
that we need stability or
a home or i don't know those home
comforts to make ourselves happy so i
think about sometimes in my life where i
where i was a freelancer kind of like
drifting through the world i could do it
for a short period of time but in the
long term i ultimately craved that sense
of home again
so
i think we need both right i think we
need the balance i think the story that
most of us don't realize is that every
one of us wants an adventure and every
one of us wants stability every one of
us wants at a point in time a long-term
committed wonderful connected
relationship and a little and at other
times once the parties and the fun and
uh
you know russian experience and and so
on and i think context is a big part of
what we miss as humans that that through
life
context changes okay and i've i've been
on an interesting journey because of
course you can imagine i have always
been extreme in whichever stage i had
been in my life when i when i became you
know
a business executive i was a very
serious business executive you know that
the 12 14 hour days the you know the
constant
hopping around the world and so on and
so forth when i became an author i
became a very serious author you know i
i started to really really spend a lot
of hours writing and you know
documenting my my thoughts and i write
two or three books at the same time
when you're extreme in those things you
tend to be
quite a bit
blinded if you want by the pace by the
detail you're swamped into it and it
does take uh
um
it does take challenging yourself if you
want to to get to a point where you say
perhaps perhaps this was wonderful for
my last seven years of my life but
perhaps
you know context has changed perhaps i
need to to explore another part of my
life to reach that point where i feel
complete and was there something that
some kind of signal that life gave you
that said it's time to pack up and flow
what was that
for most of us who rush really fast in
life we don't even recognize what we
feel we don't even even recognize what
our hearts what our souls what our
bodies are signaling to us
and and i think there has been a very
strong longing in my life
uh
to to live that idea of uh i call it
half monk
which you know
interestingly again the way we stack
life is quite strange and so you you you
we work really really really hard for
the first 30 or 40 years of our lives
and then we retire when we can't really
enjoy life you know it's like when you
retire you're basically taking your
stick and going to wherever florida or
whatever
when it's actually the way life should
be is that you probably should
take the 10 years of retirement divide
them across the 40 years and perhaps
take three months off every year if if
we were to redesign life you know it
would be wonderful to work seven months
of every year and take three more or
nine months of every year and take three
months off similarly
you know if you look even at the
spiritual path of some uh um
uh some of the most renowned monks in
the world
you go through a certain path through
life and then you stop completely and
then you go become like a monk
you know for a for uh for a while and
then you know you may come back to life
or become something else and i decided
there would be an interesting ambition
uh to
to to investigate the possibility of
maybe 50 of your life as a monk and 50
as a modern-day warrior as i call it
right and i took the number 50 because
that's how mathematicians will work i'll
start from the midpoint and then you
know irritate around it maybe i'll end
at 60 or whatever okay
and it's actually interestingly possible
it's interestingly possible to
uh spend 50 percent of your days
uh
in
in monk-like activities which would be
connection reflection uh you know
some some stillness and silence some
service uh to the world and fifty
percent completely engaged in uh you
know
writings and writing i consider as a
service but you know like business and
business conversations and you know
coaching and whatever it is
else that i do being stuck in traffic
and so on and so forth okay and it was a
stupid ambition but then it started to
become a lot more
viable in my mind that actually i could
do that at 50 percent of every day 50 of
every week 50 of every year could
actually be spent that way and and then
and the thing you need to to make that
happen is to step out of the mainstream
of your steady life okay so i had a
wonderful conversation with my uh
manager munir who uh you know really
wants our success and the success of the
mission but that sometimes makes him
push me very hard to add stuff in my
calendar and i said can you allow me the
life of a creative
so can you cram my tuesdays and
wednesdays to the point where i start
hating you
but then leave my rest of the week free
with one day that is negotiable between
us okay and that basically is even
better than 50 50. and so so in those
two days i'm completely a modern day
warrior completely engaged in you know
whatever the modern world wants from me
but then that allows me the rest of the
week if you want to do the other things
that may allow me to
find and reflect and maybe maybe figure
something out that is so much better for
the days where i get uh engaged right so
if my if my work is to spread some ideas
then silence to find those ideas is
actually useful for it
and so that was the the feeling you said
what what what was the the signal the
feeling has been there for quite a bit
of time and then when the landlord said
hey by the way want the apartment back i
was like great let's do this let's leave
the mainstream
okay let's go somewhere
and see where that takes us see where
where serendipity will
will show us i think that's an
interesting place to be
are you single
ah
i am single and not single i think oh
that that may get a lot of people
judging me
uh so i again in an interesting way
uh
found that
my current lifestyle does not qualify me
if you want for a committed relationship
okay but that a committed relationship
is one specific definition
of relationships that i think our world
has stuck to for a period of time that
evolved okay there are multiple multiple
multiple definitions of relationships
today i think if you if you look back 20
years
30 years at most you'd realize that that
singular
traditional model excluded all same-sex
relationships all by sexual
relationships all this and all of that
it also included uh it also excluded
relationships that were not uh till
death do us part and so on and so forth
i found and i say that with
worry that people will judge me i found
that what i'm doing is more important to
me at the moment
than a
traditional committed relationship okay
simply because i feel that an hour spent
with one person
could also be an hour that i spend
helping a thousand people okay and even
though that hour for me
uh uh is definitely enriching and
fulfilling and so on and so forth
it becomes sometimes
um
the commitment associated with it
doesn't make it an hour normally makes
it several hours makes it a big chunk of
your life that i
lived for 27 years and loved and i would
say it's the absolute best way
to live altogether right but it's
definitely not something that from
a current phase of my life where the the
focus of where i want to put my
chips if you want my hours of my life is
where i want to be
and so i end up when in in very very
connected very deep very uh wonderful
and loving relationships
that are
super honest but
not lasting
uh you know if my life will take me
from here to somewhere else
i will not consider sticking around here
as a prerequisite to find or you know
being a prerequisite to find a
relationship more important than my
journey of finding where i need to be i
i learned that interestingly when i
spoke to my dear friend matthew ricard
on on slo-mo so so matthieu is uh is
probably one of the most renowned monks
in the world he uh was a phd in
molecular biology if i remember
and he quit his life and went and became
a monk and he had 60 000 hours of
lifetime meditation which reconfigured
his brain in a way that that was
publicly a very very interesting science
study he was called the happiest man in
the world because of that and i asked
him and i said why matthew why why would
you leave your life and your girlfriend
and your you know your
he was french living in paris and your
phd and and go and become a a monk and
he
he said it would be very unfair
uh to
have someone in my life expect me to be
there all the time when what i wanted
was my pilgrimages and to be next to my
teachers and my time of isolation and my
alone time in my hermitage and so on and
so forth he basically said it's not a
promise i can make if i make it i would
be lying
and i think that probably was a very
enlightening moment for me because there
are many things i give up on in my life
that would make my life richer
but they're perhaps not on my path at
least not for the time being
is this uh do you view that as a phase
in your life would you view that
definitely everything is a phase in your
life definitely definitely i think
that's the the the changing context
steve is probably the biggest failure of
humanity
the changing context is
we have a tendency because we are
designed as survival machines
to
want things to remain exactly the same
if it's comfortable if it's safe
let's keep it right i want my same
coffee machine every day because i know
that machine i know it really well i can
make amazing coffee with it right and so
of course when it's time to pack things
i needed to hug that machine and say
okay baby i'm not going to see you for a
few months
but the truth is there are many places
all over the world that will make an
amazing coffee too right at that
attachment is one of the biggest reasons
for unhappiness in life
it's the idea of
i want my glass of water i don't want a
glass of water i want my mug i want my
glass of water i want my streets i want
my
commute every day i want my job security
and so on and so forth
which is beautiful and by the way every
single one of us needs to
live that for a phase of our life for a
season if you want okay
but that failure to recognize the
changing seasons
sometimes results in a narrowness of our
life
that makes us stick to one path
when when when we spoke about you
you you started as a ceo of a marketing
very successful business and now you're
a podcast host you're an author you're
on dragon's den and so on and so forth
that's a recognition within you
that this phase has served its purpose
and there is something else i need to do
with my life and by the way you could go
back to that same phase right you could
become a ceo again at a point in time
and it's that seasonal view of life and
and big part of flow
you know where i'm trying to live my
life now is to recognize those seasons
is to say look
i had an amazing amazing woman for 27
years right and i had a family i have
been there i have done that i've enjoyed
it tremendously it enriched my life but
it left gaps behind that need to be
fulfilled or completed with other phases
and other seasons okay and and i think
the game here is to be able to allow
yourself
to rather than plan and say my safety my
security my everything to allow yourself
to sit back and say what where is what's
what's life saying
is life hinting that i should be in
london
i can be in london let me be in london
right let's see maybe at the end of that
season
nothing's going to happen you're going
to go like oh it was just very good
coffee and a conversation with stephen
right and and it could be that you know
oh my god it was the best coffee of my
life and the best conversation i ever
had right and and i think that uh wisdom
if you want
uh
it depends on if you're spiritual or not
if if you believe that there is a part
to you that is not physical
call it consciousness or call it a soul
if you're spiritual
that part is
senses things that are a little bit
beyond the limitations of the physical
they it might sense
you know a need for the rest of being
someone else somewhere that may benefit
from my presence in london or maybe a a
need in within me to get a little bit of
rain which i hadn't seen for i don't
know right and if
the way the way that other part of you
communicates to you is through intuition
it cannot plant a
text message in your head and say by the
way by the 14th you need to be in london
it just gets you gives you that feeling
of
something is
missing from here and something needs to
be attended to there do you want to
investigate
and i found from the spiritual teachers
and happiness teachers and actually
business teachers that i worked with in
my life
that those who are abe who are able to
go like let me find out
okay let me find out let me check this
out
normally stumble upon some of the
biggest changes
to to our lives all of us not dutch just
their lives
and you know and it's it's quite
interesting because um
if you really look back at your life
really
most of the events that actually shaped
you that actually changed your lives
were not planned at all
you know they're probably those were
always those surprises and often were
the surprises you didn't want
okay and then somehow you go through
with them
and you end up in a place that suddenly
you recognize and go like ah
that's why i've been walking for the
last 14 days and by the way the game in
my view i i say life is a quest it's not
a journey okay and the difference
between a journey and a quest is when
you're on a journey you've sort of
plotted your path okay i'm gonna take
that flight i'm gonna go to this place
i'm gonna stay in that hotel um it's a
journey right and it will eventually end
up in a destination right a quest is
very different the quest is christopher
columbus taking a crew on a ship and in
the middle of the
you know fog
not knowing where the new world really
is okay that's a quest you know you
don't really know where the destination
is
you're basically taking a couple of
steps forward and then stopping and then
looking at the fog and then assessing
and then reflecting and then saying
maybe i should take a step left and then
you take one step left and then you say
okay how does it feel now do i want to
go to forward again or do i want to go
one step back and by the way there's
absolutely nothing wrong with taking two
steps forward assessing going to the
left and then saying uh left wasn't what
i was supposed to do i'll go back and
take a step to the right and and see
what happens
but like christopher columbus you
you set off on your quest i'm sure as
christopher columbus did
for
a reason you wouldn't load up the ship
and put all those men on the ship and
get a boat and
there has to be some kind of inspiration
or some kind of reason why you set off
that's the question i want to ask but i
was also compelled by you said you were
in a relationship 28 years and
eventually
there's something missing
yeah
there's always there is always something
missing what was what was missing
so let's talk about the big picture
first because i think people need to
understand that there's nothing wrong
with having anything missing okay but we
are a very complex being
that is made up of so many emotions and
so many reflections and so many traumas
and so many
stories and backgrounds and desires
and we live in a very very very very
unsimplifiable
world okay
and yet we try to simplify it rather
than try to enjoy it fully
okay when you when when they tell you uh
sweet and sour chicken in a chinese
restaurant
it's not just a little bit of sweet and
a little bit of sour there is a ton of
flavor happening within all of this okay
there is there are layers of complexity
that creates a life that's worth living
and for all for every one of us it's
that attachment
it's the attachment of but i like this i
don't want to change this that deprives
us of all of the other flavors right
nibel and i i i believe nibel made me my
my ex-wife she we met when she
was 18 in university
we fell in love madly we got married uh
the day she finished university uh you
know we spent 22 years together uh with
our beautiful children and then life
changed context the context changed ali
left our world my son
and when ali left our world i hit the
pedals and went double speed
when ali left our left our world nibel
on the other hand looked at her life and
said
for the first time i can now focus on me
my my children left one went to
university in canada area and ali left
the world to his next journey and you
know simply she she looked at herself
and said okay it's my time
i'm not gonna define my life by you
anymore i can't travel the world with
you because of your passion and your uh
mission and what you've now assigned
yourself as the new task i'm going to
find
what i want to do with my life and i i
think that's wonderful if you're if you
ask me that's definitely what everyone
should do
now with that contradiction
it we became further and further apart
remember love and relationships
are not ever taken for granted i always
say this openly i fell in love with
nibel six times
okay i fell in love with that cute girl
that i met in university then i fell in
love again when she became my wife
because when you're
your girlfriend and your wife you're two
different people and by the way i was
her boyfriend and her husband these are
two different people too and now
suddenly we're left with those boyfriend
girlfriend gone and the husband and wife
looking at each other and saying where's
my sweetheart
right and then suddenly you know most
people would get into that stage in one
of those
constant changes and and say hey you
know i don't like this i want my
sweetheart back you know it's an
attachment
or you can go like okay the sweetheart
is gone but oh my god this one is so
cute
right and when when you actually see it
that way you fall in love again with a
totally different person and then again
and then again i i believe i counted six
times okay
and then eventually when we wanted to to
have our different
focuses in life
i would call that falling in love again
but slightly differently because you see
the the the the thing that we
miss in life is
we define love
love is too big
if you ask me as a concept to fit within
romance
okay we've we've narrowed love down to
that story that hollywood told us which
is love is just romance okay it's a it's
a romantic relationship between two
people it has intimacy in it and it has
to be this and that and they have to
live that way okay the truth is no i i
believe there are 20 ways two partners
can enjoy and benefit from the company
of each other and grow together uh two
of which are sex and intimacy and we've
defined love
uh a per as per sex and intimacy okay
so if you if she's not your woman as in
as in you're sleeping together does that
end the love in any way okay uh you know
as a matter of fact if if it ends the
love then it was never love if you
really think about it huh and and so we
we define
our
our relationships that way and i i think
that's a recipe for disappointment
because in reality every every
relationship will always go through
those changes there will be times where
sex won't be great and there will be
other times when your spiritual
connection is at its best and you know
it really is entirely around again the
layers and the flavors and how you can
choose each one of those and embrace it
and grow it and and and make it a a
prominent
live it as much as you can with that
person
and yeah if if one of them
ends
my feeling is that the rest should not
end the rest should grow
you more than anyone though after those
20 plus years of being in a committed
relationship will understand the value
of that committed relationship and
um the place that it would i'm presuming
add value to your life now but i guess
there's an equation you're doing about
what you would what would come at the
expense of that and it sounds like
from my perspective the thing that would
come at the expense of that is your
mission your freedom which you are also
spending some time to really
indulge in
no i'm as i i think we all make those
choices all the time it just suddenly
becomes
quite contentious when it's about love
and relationship okay but you know what
you you know i left an apartment that i
enjoyed
because i needed to do something else
right i am here in london where when i
could be
in uh silicon valley for example because
they wanted me to talk about innovation
there because i need to be in london
because i want my next book to succeed
right so so we me we all make those
uh you know choices all the time
and and
life sadly is a question of compromise
because
you know you you you you often say that
the best of both worlds doesn't happen
you can't you cannot have best of both
worlds you can you can either say i'm
living
fully
as my number one priority to achieve a
and i'll achieve as much as i can of b
as long as it doesn't contradict a or
you can say i'll go for b and you know
i'll sacrifice a bit of a for that right
and and it's interesting because most
people especially the romantics will say
how can you sacrifice love you know love
is the most important no a billion happy
is more important than love
in all honesty for me and my to my
personal love okay because in in in my
capacity to
to feel love for a billion people okay
and actually try and dedicate my life to
as many as i can reach with that
i tend to believe that's
that
prioritizing my own comforts and my own
life and my own
settlement if you want being settled
is selfish to be honest it's it's a
different phase it hopefully will happen
in two three years time but it's not the
phase now it's not the right time for it
at all okay and yes i wish i could get a
b again get a and b and maybe i'll
stumble upon that wonderful woman that
is completely aligned and you know
spends the that my trips with me and you
know supports this
and if i do that's amazing but if i
don't what would i prioritize it's life
is a question of choices
you could be doing anything with your
time
you know
you're clearly someone that is make
being very intentional about the use of
your time and making sure that every
hour of your time is allocated towards
what you want whether that is playing
video games whether it is writing a book
so why did you choose to write a book
called that little voice in your head
i feel that the top three reasons for
unhappiness in the world
uh
without competition beyond that like
they are by far
bigger than all of the others are
ego
lack of self-love and actually in order
it would be lack of self-love ego and
that little voice in your head okay and
the little voice in your head
as i as i say at the beginning of the
book that i would dare say that there
has never
been a moment in your life
where any event had the
power to make you unhappy until you
turned it into a thought okay so so
anything could happen
it's the story you tell yourself about
it that makes you unhappy it's not the
event it's the story right and so if my
if i'm true to my
commitment to try and
make the world happier then i need to
talk about those three topics in three
different
books if you if you want or maybe some
content of some form but but that's not
the point the point is what's tag what's
what struck me and really really puzzled
me was that i realized uh when i wrote
scary scarysmart and you know scarysmart
was entirely about technology and where
technology is going and so on i realized
that we humans
have the ultimate technology in our
heads a brain that is so sophisticated
so capable of doing things that are
really really beyond the capacity of any
supercomputer still today
and yet we know how to use our
smartphones and our devices better than
we know how to use that brain
most people get trained on how to use
excel but they never really get trained
on
how to streamline the thoughts in their
head okay and and that appeared to me to
be a very interesting engineering
problem and so the idea was to create
that analogy between neuroscience and
computer science so the book in my mind
was if i can show people that those
brains the neuroscience of them is is
actually similar very analogous to
computer science and the devices you
have in your hand
because people already know how to use
those devices then that knowledge would
allow them to use the brain
as good as they use the devices
the basics here
which is the the title of the first
chapter of your book
and it's and it feels like the first
chapter really kind of introduces some
of the
inspiration behind you why you wrote
wrote the book you talk a lot about your
wife and the illusions that you live
under
what are the illusions that you you live
under
or you lived under
again let's
think about the bigger picture first
everything that we have you haven't
visited and investigated
and arrived at a competent confident uh
conviction that this is your own view
is probably an illusion
okay which is quite striking because for
a man like me who
spends a lot of his time reflecting
uh we're surrounded we're submerged in
illusions okay everything from the value
of uh
you know a branded bag all the way to
you know what the tv is telling us what
the government is supposed to do and all
of that stuff
unless you've reflected on it and said
okay i'm being told this
i'm
you know behaving this way which might
be contradicting what i've been told but
i'm feeling that way which might be a
third contradiction and where is my
reality
it's safe to assume that this was an
illusion so a big part of that little
voice in your head is an admission of
all of the mistakes i made using that
machine in my life or not all but many
not even many but many mistakes that
i've made using this machine not all of
them there are many more mistakes
one i think the biggest of them was a
conviction in my early years that my
kids were a burden my family was a
responsibility okay
which does happen
when they come to life when you're very
young i mean i had ali when i was 25
i was
just turned 26
and and uh and uh and uh you know i got
married when i was 25 so basically
you start to feel responsible you start
to prioritize work you start to go out
in that treadmill uh you know the
hedonic treadmill and just run run run
run run run okay and and the pressure
that you that you put on yourself when
you do that
makes you start to think
okay
they are the reason why i'm working so
hard they are the reason why i'm
stressed okay when in reality if you had
asked them they would have said papa
just come play with us right we don't
want more than what we have it's me
losing context and running like crazy
that made me think that way and the
basics of the challenges we have with
our brains
is that we believe what our brains tell
us okay so when my brain tell me they
are
the the burden they are the challenge my
whole being responds to that my whole
being starts to behave that way okay
and and i think what the reality
that we miss when we do those things
becomes
uh what you have seen in the if you if
you like the movie inception um you know
when she when his wife
had that
um
thought uh you know we're waiting for a
train or train you know basically that
kept playing in her head over and over
and over that convinced her that this is
not the real world that they are in a
dream and that the way to go out of it
is to die that actually led her to
committing suicide and and and you know
big opening of the movie that my
favorite movie line of all time is what
is the most resilient parasite okay and
the most resilient parasite is not a
bacteria it's not a virus it is a
thought that you implant deep in your
brain and believe in it over and over
and over through your life and it shapes
everything
shapes everything interestingly without
you even knowing
why you're doing what you're doing is
because
because of that thought because of that
belief because of that ideology
and people do the weirdest things i i
have a very very dear friend who is a
brilliant engineer brilliant engineer
who had that thought in his head uh he's
now in his early 60s
that
if i tell my ideas to a businessman
he's going to steal it
so every startup he ever attempted he
wanted to be the engineer and the ceo
okay and as a result everything he
started failed even though the ideas and
the engineering the the the rigor was
incredible
but he just couldn't get that idea out
of his mind and and you can go all the
way to people who have ideas that lead
to wars or to destruction or to
terrorist acts or whatever it's just one
idea seeded deep enough in our head that
really leads us to become who we are and
digging out that idea and finding it
that's the basic
the basic is to find those thoughts
and how you can deal with them so that
you eradicate them so that you can
actually live through to who you are not
the thoughts that have been implanted in
your brain
and how does one go about even knowing
where to start that search for those
sort of limiting or imprisoning thoughts
that are
have become the satellite navigation of
our lives it is um
it's a moment of truth it's a moment of
honesty you know i i think you started
with that very
uh i can't believe i spoke about that
about the very personal question about
my relationship choices
right but that's a moment of truth it's
not that i don't want someone in my life
but it's that if that someone
contradicts priority a then priority a
is actually what i stand for right and
and you get those by comparing what
you're thinking
to what you actually do and what you
actually feel
and it's a very interesting exercise if
you're coherent in something if you say
i am vegan for example okay if if you
identify yourself as vegan
but you crave eating animal protein
and you feel that you're
pressured then you're not a vegan
okay you could be a striving vegan
you're trying to be vegan you could be
an ideologist vegan you want you believe
in the ideology of veganism but you're
not
don't call yourself i am a vegan okay
you can then change that thought and say
i want to be vegan
okay that's a different thought than i
am vegan
and and you can apply that to everything
to every part of your life i am in that
partnership
i love her and i want to stay with her
forever
but i'm looking at every other woman and
i feel that i'm in jail okay great have
that conversation
with yourself have that conversation
with yourself because what you're
feeling is contradicting what you're
doing is contradicting what you're
thinking so much of my life is filled
with contradict absolutely
what does that say so i'm thinking about
you know i i say that i want to be in a
committed relationship but then i s what
i do
is
work all the time and want to work all
the time
and choose work all the time
um so what does that mean
what does that mean you can tell me on
the camera i'm not gonna cry
it is uh it's it's really it is look
you're not alone all of us are and it's
not on one topic it's on every topic
okay so so there are as i always talk
about there are three compartments in
our brains okay one compartment is what
i call compartment one which are things
that are true and we know are true okay
the other is compartment three which are
things that are that are not true and we
know they're not true okay and the
majority of what's happening inside us
is what i call compartment two which are
things that are needed undecided we
either don't know them or we know that
they're not aligned but we can live with
them for now we don't prioritize them
what matters is not solving them
what matters is marking them as
compartment two if you mark them as
compartment two in your head you go like
okay hold on this topic is unresolved
it's not within my priority today but i
need to come back to that topic just as
just like my choice of relationships
right you know it takes a long time and
a lot of experimenting after my
separation with my with my wife to try
and get to a point where i actually know
that i'm going to put in the time and
investigate where i am in life
during throughout that time i i
acknowledge to myself and i say this is
compartment two i don't know what i want
i don't right and the point is so many
of those exist if you live assuming that
it's compartment one you're completely
messed up
right because your actions are not
matching your your feelings and your
feelings are not matching your thoughts
okay you're not you're not complete
you're not
full you're not settled you know we we
you know that that idea of
equilibrium
most people the easiest way to imagine
it
visually is to imagine a pendulum right
if your life is in equilibrium it's in
total balance
that total balance is the point at which
uh
minimal effort is needed to live
if you're in balance you're not
struggling okay just like the pendulum
depending on when it's at it's a
equilibrium point
you literally need zero force to keep it
in the equilibrium point forever you
don't have to apply any force to it you
want to push it a little bit to the
right
you have to apply a force and keep that
force for as long as you you want it to
stay within that place and that's what
we do with our lives all the time that
our nature our balance our equilibrium
is not exactly how we're living and so
we're constantly applying effort we're
constantly trying to be in a place
that is not our natural place to be we
want to be there so we apply the effort
is there anything wrong with that
absolutely not because life is cyclical
okay and life is all compromises as we
start but the the trick is to say
when i am in that place
i am aware that this place is not my
natural tendency and i am okay with that
because that place gives me a b and c
there is a utility to that place
at the same time i want to tell myself
openly that i'm heading from that place
to that point of equilibrium
could that could be by saying in the
next seven years i'm not going to do
anything about it but in seven years
time i'm going to start to head in that
equilibrium or you could say i'm going
to take a step every day for the next
seven years whichever way you want and
or you by the way or you can also tell
yourself
i don't care
i know it's not my equilibrium but i'm
going to do it anyway because that's
what i believe in i think that's very
much at the state i'm in okay if you ask
me i'd like to be in you know 50 percent
of the year doing absolutely nothing
okay with someone i absolutely love
with some a very simple life but that's
not my life every day and i know that to
be true and i will do it for a while to
go you know because i have a i have
assigned myself something that i believe
requires that effort
okay the other thing that humans do most
of us is we leave a lot of pendulums out
of it out of equilibrium so so it's
actually quite easy to tell yourself
look my number one pendulum is my work
okay i'm going to put that in
equilibrium
then my second uh uh
importance is relationship or reverse
them if you want the third is my impact
the fourth is my friendships the fifth
is my health and so on and and then the
game is if you want your work to
actually benefit
put the others in equilibrium
okay or acknowledge to yourself that
they're not but you but don't complain
about it don't feel bad about it okay
and if you do that you manage to then
simply focus yourself on the one that is
your most priority and then life is in
an interesting way linear that way in in
physics it's basically it's instead of
the parallel processing of trying to fix
all of them at the same time you're
simply saying i'm gonna
process them in series i'm gonna fix
this work element pendulum first and
when it's done i'll fix the next one and
then when it's done i'll fix the next
one and it's a constant journey so
you're not alone i'm exactly like you
constantly constantly searching and
constantly
reflecting and investigating and finding
that equilibrium
just going back to something you said
there about what you'd probably want is
it a case that you don't believe you
could live a life where you have
priority of your mission
one one billion happy
and
a partner who is
is not impeding on the mission
no absolutely not i believe it's 100
possible just not met the person yet
absolutely okay okay the economics of
love and romance are quite
shocking most people don't understand
how that works you know if you have if
you have one requirement in the if you
have zero requirements in the person
that you need in your life
uh walk out of your door
the first person that you meet is that
person right because you have zero
anything that this person is is okay for
you if you have one requirement and and
say one of every 10 people in the world
has that requirement
okay brunette yeah yeah yeah or
something deeper you know let's start
you know i am straight so i need a woman
okay that by definition removes 50
percent of the population yeah okay uh i
i'm you know i need a certain age
bracket in my life that by
by itself removes maybe 70 percent of
the remaining population and so on so
every layer that you add to your
requirements
sadly follows the n squared problem okay
so the n squared problem is if you're
looking for a person with one criteria
and one in every ten persons have that
if you add another layer of criteria
it's not one in twenty it's one in a
hundred
if you add the third criteria it's one
in a thousand if you add a third fourth
criteria it's one and ten thousand right
so it's constantly ten to the power off
right now
if if you take anything that you want
i'm i'm looking for someone for example
supportive of my mission and free to
travel
whatever that is
if
if that person
is you know is described by six criteria
you're now talking about one
in a hundred thousand do they exist
absolutely
absolutely hundred percent
do i have the time to spend looking for
one in a hundred thousand
i don't
i do but it's not my priority
do you understand and we do that with
everything in life you you invest in
your six-pack
i invest in my little belly right
why because for you
the i the ability to prioritize the
six-pack at your age with your current
you know a lifestyle and so on is
actually taking a certain amount of
investment from you that's justifiable
by the roi
okay for me if i wanted to achieve your
six-pack i'd probably take double the
time maybe double the effort right and
at the same time i would require a
lifetime that has a lifestyle that has a
consistency in it
that i may not be able to to achieve now
and you look at it and you go like damn
you steve i want a six-pack but then at
the same time i tell myself but then you
mow you're traveling everywhere and
you're really really being true to
yourself that's fine it's a reasonable
compromise okay so so the question just
to be very specific everything exists
but the probabilities
of them happening if i'm the luckiest
person on earth
okay
i would walk out of here and she's the
first person i meet right but if you
count that and say no reasonable
probability you will say you'd have to
encounter 50 000 encounters for that
person to show up if you're unlucky not
unlucky and not lucky
right suddenly it starts to become
interesting you tell yourself and i know
this sounds really weird for the
romantics by the way i'm i'm completely
a love
you know
junkie
but but but there is a reality to life
that sometimes gets you to prioritize
things differently it's really
interesting because i've never heard
anybody describe it in like a
mathematical way before
yeah
you know so there is mathematics
underlying everything i mean think about
that idea of one in a hundred thousand
right the mathematics of that it is it's
true when you see the mathematics
doesn't mean that you have to
act in a way that's not human but it
just allows you to understand how the
system is working so that you can fit in
so the example i gave is you're if
you're into shelby cobras right if you
want to sell that one car among a
million other cars on on on a site
that million other that car will have
very little chance of being found on a
general site but for the fans of a
shelby cobra if you go to a show of
shelby cobras everyone there a hundred
percent of the people there are
interested in it okay so the interesting
bit is that you can actually increase
your probability of being found quite a
lot if you're true to yourself
if you start to advertise yourself
exactly who you as as who you are and
mix with the people that you believe are
the people that you want to be with
right that's
it changes the probability drastically
actually
that's so very very true
that's very very true kind of goes back
to what i was saying when i did your
podcast about my
hairdresser who was dripping head to toe
in the material position
he's advertising himself to a certain
audience that he doesn't actually want
to attract and if he is successful in
that advertisement he'd attract
something that makes him unhappy and
gives them shitty relationships so
you get exactly what you advertise and
that's the interesting thing you know if
if a young lady wants to to find a
committed partner but goes to the pub
every friday evening or the or the club
every friday evening to find that
partner you know dressed in a certain
way
acting in a certain way she's gonna get
the person because people are you know
we don't see beyond what you're
advertising so if that's what you're
advertising the person who's interested
in this will show up right if you're
into tango dancing
and you sho and you go to a tango class
the people there will be interested in
tango
and and those people will be the ones
that you want to create that
relationship with and yeah of course
there are not a million people in the
city that are interested in tango but a
hundred percent of the people that are
in that class are
so i guess you get what your
advertisement attracts so be careful
what you advertise absolutely and and to
advertise correctly the one thing you
need most is to know actually who you
are
what are you as a product right most
people don't know that i still don't
know who they are absolutely you don't
you don't know what who you are
multiple multiple uh layers of confusion
you don't know who you are
you don't love who you are
you know or love who you are
but you're advertising differently
because you think others are more
interesting
okay
uh or by the way you don't know what you
want so one one of the most
eye-opening one of the chapters so i'm
writing all of this in a book called
finding love one of the most interesting
chapters is all the models of love okay
and it's so eye-opening today someone in
my generation only believed that the
only way to be with with with someone is
to have a traditional relationship
look at all of the models that are
available in today's world you know
with all the way from hookups to our
lifetime commitment everything's
available all you know and and when you
when you when you don't know what you're
looking for then you're advertising
wrong how do you find out what you're
looking for though again it's the
triangle
what is what am i thinking what am i
feeling and what am i doing
okay so
openly
some of us will say especially if you
may say say for example you're
a woman in her 30s
okay uh and you want a child you want a
child you you feel it in you
but you're so
you know so so when you look at the
triangle what you feel is i want a child
but your actions are you're dating
people without talking about the topic
okay and then what you're thinking is
maybe if i if i tell them i want a child
they will not want to be with me
which is quite interesting because yes
if they don't want to be with you when
you don't want a child you don't want to
be with them either
right and and accordingly there is a
contradiction
if you want a child you want to
advertise to the world openly to say
when you meet someone before you get too
involved you say what's your position on
the topic
isn't it so funny that our strategy
tends to be the total opposite it's
false advertise until we get them
because the false advertisement's going
to get more people
and then once we've got them switch up
gradually
um well i don't even know if it's a
conscious decision to switch up
gradually but it's an inevitable
inevitability you can't act for years so
eventually once we've got them on the
false advertisement of who we think we
they wanted us to be
then we'll change and that's when all
the conflict and relationships happen is
when absolutely
this is not what you wanted at all yeah
and you've attracted you're
you attracted the wrong person and
you're stuck by acting yeah but but the
more interesting part of this is
uh
we we're prioritizing for the wrong
target so remember you if you really sit
with yourself and you say what do i want
from a relationship i want a committed
partner that wants to have a family with
me if you if you come to that choice
you would behave very differently but
interestingly you have this other
conflicting
thing of but i want reassurance that i'm
interested interesting and people are
still you know men are still attracted
to me so i'm going to go out dating
others who are not
just to make sure that when i find this
guy i'll i'll be i'll be you know still
still
ready to to grab right that doesn't make
any sense at all because by the way the
ones that you're attracting are not
resembling a sample to what you're
actually looking for
and i know it sounds really weird when
you talk about those things in
mathematics and probabilities and sets
and subsets and so on but believe it or
not it's entirely and i know people will
hate me when i say this dating is an
entirely an economics problem it is
economics economics meaning
in my days when i met nibel she was one
of 14
friends i knew okay the economics were
very straightforward of the 14 nibel was
the one that matched my soul most she
was the most beautiful woman on the
planet for those 14 and everyone else
and so i said i'm after this one
right
today from a supply and demand point of
view you're talking about 14 million
people at any point in time that are in
a market that is so complex it's like
the nasdaq market
okay literally if products are on the
market instantly all the time
and and the game isn't a game of
economics sadly the more supply there is
the less the value of a product
right so if if you simply said to
yourself you know a um
this camera is now going to be uh we're
going to make 14 million copies of it
because it's easier for the factory to
make 14 million copies than to make 4
000.
every one of those copies to manage to
sell 14 has to go down in price
okay because otherwise peop only people
who uh can afford the four thousand
would buy and then you'll be left with
the other ten
and that's what's happening in the
dating and romance market is that there
is so much
supply out there that nobody values that
relationship anymore everyone is like
okay i'll try anyway you know it's gonna
what it's going what's it what is it
gonna take a couple of dates but then
that's not what happened you go on a
couple of dates and then it's a nice
case and then you stay a little longer
and then right and and all of that
basically you realize that you've spent
seven months of your life to figure out
that this person is not interested in
children for example if we take that
example so what does that mean in real
time say that i was single
and i was looking
right
i'm someone you know who what i'm like
i'm someone that's deeply interested in
ideas and thoughts and you know
self-development and all of these things
you know what i'm interested in we've
talked long enough for you to have a at
least a gauge of that where would i
go
is it a place
and where would i not go
it could be i mean if you want to find
love do what you love
very straightforward if you're into
reflection and personal development go
to personal development conferences sit
with personal development uh people like
me i'll buy you coffee anytime uh you
know and or or or
you know go to a retreat for example the
people that will go to the retreat will
be the type of person that you're
looking for i'm i gave that advice to
one of my dear friends and colleagues
when i worked at google she was part of
google in poland and i told her that i
said if you want to find love do what
you love so she went and asked herself
what do i love i love tango
went and started you know attended the
tango class ended up marrying the the
the instructor right it's simple you you
want someone that matches you go to the
places where those things happen those
places could be physical places they
could be online okay they could be
serendipitous because you're searching
for those things but just know
what you stand for
i'm you know
not a party animal i'm never gonna find
my
match in a party
so so do i go to parties no i don't
really i mean i i go sometimes when
there is a reason to go but otherwise no
that's not how i spend my time
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
you asked me a question about money and
then
you said you know what does money mean
to me and then when i asked you you said
you think you've come to learn that you
think money is one of your illusions
what do you mean by that
money is an illusion at every every
level
money doesn't exist you and i know that
anyone who understands fractional
reserve and how money is printed and
generated money does not even exist you
walk into a bank and you ask for a 50
000 pounds loan for a car and they
literally write the numbers five zero
zero zero zero in a spreadsheet and poof
money comes out of nowhere that money
never existed before you borrowed it
okay and will only exist when you work
your backside off to pay it back right
and interestingly that in that illusion
uh was created to make our lives easier
and then it ended up create making our
life a lot more difficult now
why because most of us
are so chasing the revenue side of money
without a full understanding of the cost
side of money
let me try to explain
for you to get a job in london that pays
you a hundred thousand pounds
just for simplification of the
mathematics you have to live in london
which costs you
seventy thousand pounds for example i
don't know london very well but let's
say these are the numbers but on top of
the seventy thousand pounds it also
causes costs you str your stress
it also costs you being far away from
your mom if your mom lives elsewhere it
costs you you know your time which is
your most valuable resource the only
thing you really have in your life is
your time and it costs you so many other
things right and so most people uh uh
don't understand the the cost
uh benefit relationship to start now you
you take that and then you add a louis
vuitton bag or a fancy car and suddenly
your money is not even going as far as
it could because you could get yourself
a bag
that is beautiful and everything for 100
pounds but then you choose to to buy one
for several thousand pounds and then you
have to work harder which makes you may
pay more costs and that and the cycle
becomes even more vicious right you
continue further than that and you start
to say so i save some of that my
some of my money in the future but your
savings are suffering inflation so you
save a thousand pounds they become 900
they become 800. when in reality by the
way you've saved the thousand pounds
when you could have bought borrowed them
by entering some numbers in a
spreadsheet the entire recipe around
that story is wrong everything around
money is not what we believe in it is
okay which basis basically makes it an
illusion now the biggest part of that
illusion believe it or not is and i know
you have money in the bank
is that you have nothing i i don't know
if you realize that i most most people
don't understand that if i have a
hundred pounds in the bank i literally
have nothing i have nothing the bank has
my 100 pounds and the bank can decide
whatever they want to do if they wanted
to take it away from me okay and it is
only my money
when i choose to buy an iphone or
something with it
for that one instant
that money is mine
and then once i get the iphone it's not
mine anymore i now have the iphone
right
you basically
assign that money that is never yours
it's the banks until the minute you
spend it to spending it on things that
most of us don't ever ever interact with
i mean look at your own home anyone
listening to us and how many things you
have in that home
that you've not ever used ever you know
you you saw that pair of shoes in the
window and you were like oh my god i
have to have them spent several hundred
pounds on them or several tens of pounds
on them and then ended up taking them
home never ever putting them on
right now all of that waste along the
way the cost of earning the money the
things that you spend it on the actual
value of the thing that the things that
you spend it on basically tells you that
there is one truth
to money which is i have basic needs
i have basic needs and my basic needs
are to be reasonably covered
reasonably fed uh reasonably safe and so
on and so forth
and in in isla in the islamic culture we
call this risk which is different than
income
risk is not what how much money you earn
it's the good that that money brings you
it's did you eat a meal today that is
actually what you're looking for in life
it's not the money that gets you the
meal okay what you're looking for is the
meal could you actually buy something
for your daughter today the thing is
what you're looking for
it's not it's not the money that got the
thing
and if you start to chase that
something very different happens right
suddenly you start to ask yourself hmm
is buying that thing
worth the 17 hours of work i'm going to
put in them
right is it which of those which would i
prefer if i gave you the two choices and
said buy this bag
or spend 17 hours with your friends
if you see it that way you may make very
different decisions leaves us with the
very big other illusion which is but
money is safety mo you know it's not
like i want money because i want more
fancy things i just want to feel safe
because the world is unpredictable
sadly when the world is unpredictable
money is not going to save you okay and
i think my story has been very very very
big eye opener i had enough money
i you know i had enough connections and
enough influence and i you know failed
to protect my child's life when it was
time for him to go right i you know i
think we know many stories of someone
that maybe falls and breaks your back
what will your money do for you safety
is a much bigger thing
than just a little bit of money in the
bank and by the way safety is an
attitude it's an idea to tell yourself
when i need it i will make it when i
need it i will have it perhaps the
answer is i don't need so much of it
anyway and i think
you know again like everything in in
life you you want to to have the skill
of making money money is is power you
know again when you were speaking on
slo-mo you basically said i love the
idea of being able to build this setup
for the podcast of spending on my show
and so on that's wonderful okay money is
power
but
it's power as long as you own it and it
doesn't own you
the minute money owns you and lack of it
starts to distract you and looking at
how much your your other friend has and
he has a little more than you you know
hurts your ego once it gets into that
realm
then money works against you it doesn't
work for you do you think it's a noble
cause that when i answered that question
and i said
um for me money is basically the fuel of
my mission it enables me to i said i put
on my my diary overseer live tour it
cost me about 600 000 pounds to book
these 10 venues to book the london
palladium for three nights to book this
massive choir of you know 40 people to
book this big music there was about 100
of us 100 people i had to book and pay
for to put on that show
at the end of the show i break even but
without the that tors you know reaches
almost 20 000 people it's the most
thrilling fulfilling and uh biggest
honor that i've ever had to be able to
do that in front of all of those people
and to share that message which is very
much in line with my mission
and i look at money and said if i didn't
have the money it would have been much
much harder not impossible but much much
much harder to do that
absolutely so is do you feel like that
is a noble relationship with with money
look uh
we agree on this
nothing is good or bad nothing is right
or wrong everything is both right and
wrong and everything is can be both good
and bad it depends on what you want to
do with it and one of the messages i
constantly tell everyone in the world is
absolutely become successful become
powerful become rich
because the biggest problem with our
world is that the most successful most
powerful then and the richest are the
worst of us
okay and i don't generalize and say
that's the truth but it's actually
easier to make money if you break some
rules than if it than it is if you're
ethical and so as a result of that
a good chunk of the big money in the
world is not super ethical right and if
if i have
more money i can fuel my one billion
happy mission and that's a good thing
for the world that's by the way owning
money not letting it own you right so
what if i if i can get to the point
where i make it and actually give it to
one billion happy then that's amazing if
i get to the point where i make it and
then suddenly go like oh let's wait a
little bit grow it a tiny bit and then
give it to
1 billion happy then i'm not doing the
right thing having said that
you know of course you know how i admire
you and respect you
this is your
zoom lens of the world okay for someone
else
four pounds
some sticky paper and a couple of
scissors and spending an hour with her
daughter doing something beautiful okay
is as impactful maybe even more
impactful than the entire show because
that one daughter
with the sticky paper and scissors might
end up becoming one of the most
pronounced artists in the world
prominent enough to change the world
with four four pounds scissors and a
piece of paper right now we we somehow
especially those of us like you and i
who
who had experiences in life where they
put effort and the effort rewarded them
okay we think
that we're the ones that are changing
the world or making a difference or no
we're not okay the reality is we need we
need to understand that
again i you know i admire you and i know
you'll you'll you'll not feel upset but
half of what you know is wrong half of
what i know is wrong
absolutely right and it's it's just an
attempt it's just an attempt with you
know
whether that attempt
uh uh steve is is is an attempt because
of money or is it it's an attempt
because you just
spend time with your driver talking
about something or you know
you you you were telling the story
all of those things
i think the game is
i'm going to do the best that i can
to acquire the resources that i'm good
at acquiring to direct them in the
investments that i have accessible to me
okay if if you are a cashier uh you know
at a supermarket and you're making
enough money to
spend wonderful time with your daughter
to be you know to to do a bit of art and
that in itself is a form of contribution
that changes the world and you'll never
know that one daughter might cure cancer
it's interesting i was i was bouncing
around in my head back and forward about
like
about the role that
a lot of my i don't know maybe my
traumas and insecurities are playing in
driving my decision making around these
things obviously putting on a big show
you have lots of people there that are
clapping for you there's lots of
admiration it's very like it's very
massaging of the ego so one might say to
themselves well i'm serving the world
when in fact it's more of a selfish
thing and you're like you know what i
mean it's that that constant battle i
find in my life where the the greatest
service that i do to others is also
woven in there with loads of like
absolutely insecurity so even this
podcast like i'm sure the people
listening enjoy listening i'm sure they
get a tremendous amount of value from it
but there is still this guy in me that
is so desperate to be number one and to
win right and it's almost i'm almost at
peace with the
conflicting forces because
i know
i think as we sit here the podcast is
number one in the apple store pretty
sure of that
and i know it wouldn't have been and it
wouldn't have reached as many people if
i wasn't someone who was desperate to be
the best
but i also know that there's this that
pursuit of being the best is also quite
an ugly one because it comes means you
end up sacrificing a bunch of things in
the pursuit of being the best that might
make you more fulfilled
so it's this weird it's this weird
balancing act of contradiction and
confusion and not really knowing why i'm
doing what i'm doing at like the real
fundamental level you can broadcast what
people want you to hear oh i'm doing it
because i want to help others but i
actually know that there's it's a recipe
a concoction of many conflicting forces
and pretty much all my success has been
uh this this sort of recipe of
conflicting forces
well i mean
what i what i admire most about you is
you're able to see
and say this
okay if you're you know if you've
achieved total enlightenment you'll be
gone okay none of us is ever there that
the challenge is this
some people are completely egocentric
and not even aware
yeah okay some people
are
struggling
okay and some people
are
um you know doing the best they can
understanding as i say that in
compartment two there is something and
they're okay with it okay and the the
the trick is you're always trying to
move a little bit higher and that higher
you know and that little voice in your
head i i follow that model and it's it
sounds simple but it's actually quite
interesting i call it b learn do right
be learn do is most of us in our life we
look at problems and we say here's the
solution
right that's we're mostly almost
anchored in
doing
doing again is a very masculine trait
okay it's interestingly a lot of doing
is as harmful as it's it is as it is
beneficial
you know the the good doing is a doing
that is informed by a form of being and
by a certain level of skill that comes
from learning okay so when i what i
normally try to follow in the entire
manual to your brain is to say okay for
everything that we will find we will
have to be then learned and do
okay so you're you're very good one of
the people i respect most about that
idea of being you look at yourself and
you say oh i am doing that because of
that insecurity that happened when i was
this that's an amazing achievement in
itself that's a third of the way
right i know what's what i need to work
on and i think it's the challenging
third of the way believe it or not
because we humans are very good at
solving the problems when they're
defined if you make it your priority
you're going to learn the skill everyone
is capable of doing that again i speak a
lot about neuroplasticity and how
learning works
but once once you've learned once you've
realized what it is that you need to
work on
you're going to learn the skill and then
you're going to start practicing and
doing it the right way the challenge is
when you don't know what you're working
on now i'll say this openly
what you're doing to the world with your
awareness that part of it is ego driven
of course part of what i do is ego
driven i tell the whole world that i am
an engineer being being an engineer is
an ego right why do i tell the whole
world that there is a utility to that
ego the utility is by the way guys if
you're going to read my work or listen
to my my analysis it's going to appear a
little over engineered even when i talk
about something as beautiful as love and
relationships
right it will have that engineering
element to it which is not entirely
myself by the way it's just the way i
present myself to the world because
others don't present themselves that way
so i'm differentiating
yeah it's i wish i didn't have to use
that ego you may wish that you stood on
stage and didn't feel the rush of people
clapping and saying well done you're
amazing but by the way if you're
delivering to thousands and hundreds of
thousands of people on your podcast
great you're so much better than those
who are not
and now the fact that you have your
awareness makes you even better than
those who are but are not aware of their
uh you know the parts that they need to
work on
yeah it's challenging i think
i i think i was bouncing around in my
head on that because
if i cared a ton about the
the clapping part
i probably would be
trying to convince everybody that i'm
perfect a bit more than i do it's just a
an interesting battle of ego but i but i
also think that i think i said this on
your podcast is it's okay to be a
contradiction and i think in all facets
of my life when i look at my decisions
what i want what i say what i do and
there's so many interwoven
contradictions and it's so
remarkable that the contradictions often
lead me to success in in the things that
i'm aiming for it's not making sense i
think the whole idea is that we're all
contradictions the only difference is
you're aware
yeah you realize that huh so so the
thing i i think you should be the
example for everyone to recognize that
we're all contradictions okay it's
everyone every single one listening to
us
life is a contradiction this is why one
of my favorite feminine qualities is the
ability to embrace paradoxes right and
and the reality is the only way you can
almost like at a quantum level solve
life better is if you're able to embrace
two extremes and say both are true and
i'm going to include both of them in my
lifestyle both of them in my decision
making because both of them are me
it goes back to your point about the
equilibrium as well that the reason why
the pendulum sits in the middle is
because
it's that balance with two opposing
forces
gravity has balanced it on that
particular point but when you apply one
force to either side it will swing into
a direction maybe balance is being a
perfect contradiction absolutely balance
is always a contradiction okay balance
is is that ability to take all of those
forces now you have to imagine i i
separated them into six forces and said
your health you know suspend pendulums
your health is one and your love is one
and this is one but the reality is
you're one pendulum apply so many forces
are applying from so many directions and
the contradiction is not just if i work
harder i'll make more money or less
money if i work harder i will also be a
little more stressed if i work harder my
relationships will be affected and each
of those eventually you're ending up in
one place that is very very complex
you're we're a very complex being as a
as a human and we're dealing with an
even more complex life
and the the thing is we need to take it
easy on ourselves and say yeah yeah yeah
i'll figure out my relationship bits in
a while i now need to figure out my one
billion mission and you know a little
more or i need to figure out this more
or i need to do that more and it's okay
to say it's never perfect it's
absolutely never perfect the the game is
if i told myself no no hold on i've done
the thinking and this situation is my
perfect situation
i'm doomed because i'm basically telling
myself keep that pendulum in this place
and defend it with your life okay put
all of the effort in the world when that
pendulum is in the wrong place it's not
in balance
in your book as well that little voice
in your head you describe how like all
thoughts aren't really made equally and
that there's different sort of
categories of thoughts
and some of them like observation are
closer to the truth than others what are
the different categories of thoughts
that we have in our head
the first challenge with thought is that
we
[Music]
create our thoughts
from the wrong ingredients
so if i if i gave you
bad vegetables and told you to make the
best salad recipe on the planet it's
still going to taste bad
and and the the reality is
we have only one
proper ingredient
that we should allow into our brain so
that we create proper accurate thoughts
and that that
one ingredient is actual observation
okay observation is i look at this glass
and i say this glass is
uh 37
full
okay that is an observation yeah you can
we can debate in physics if it is or if
it isn't and so on but in in you know
the typical way we look at life this is
37 full right
my brain would then tell me
if i used that information i may ask for
someone in the team and say guys can can
i please another have another a little
bit more water my brain would then then
tell me no no hold on it's tapered
okay uh it is not you know the same from
the top
as it is in the uh from the bottom now
you you've calculated wrong no you're
getting old and your mathematics are not
accurate anymore you're you know you can
go into so many different
uh uh um
inputs into your thoughts that would
debate that fact that it is
more empty than it is full okay
you take that and you find you can find
them in categories one of them is
conditioning believe it or not
one of the most frequently used sources
for creating your thoughts is not what's
happening in the world at all it's your
conditioning
and your conditioning creates thoughts
within you that are not not at all a
reality i i i speak about an experience
where i was dating a buddhist girl who
was very calm and wonderful in every
possible way and you know two of our
best friends were a couple and they had
a big fight before coming to our uh uh
place and so anyway the the girl
basically said no i need to talk to you
about something and you know want to ask
your view and she sat next to me very
very very good friends all the four of
us for a very long time and so she she
hugged me she sat on you know put her
head on my shoulder and cried okay my
girlfriend came in and said
excuse my english she said take your
hands off my man you be
okay
and you know i was like whoa
she's one of the calmest people i know
what happened here
and what happened was she had been
cheated on before right by the best fri
by her best girlfriend
and a a you know
a friend of the person she was dating at
the time and the input into her head
that said this girl was sort of doing
something inappropriate with me it was
coming from the fact that she had that
conditioning in her it wasn't the event
itself the event was highly exaggerated
by the conditioning so we're unable to
find that when we when we look at our at
the makeup of our thoughts the second i
i and the third are recycled emotions
and recycled thoughts okay so we recycle
so much of what our parents told us
recycling of a memory or the recycling
of a thought you know your your friend
uh tells you hey by the way all men are
cheats and you recycle that thought okay
all men are cheats all men are cheats
and then you know
you you end up making decisions based on
that
the fourth and i think the most
the biggest challenge we have in the
modern world is the mainstream uh media
basically the the the large advertising
media uh story that we're told that is a
ton of input whether it's movies it's
social media it's you know tweets or or
reels or or if
it's the bbc or channel for playing the
news and the the the reality of what
we're getting is
we're getting a highly biased section of
life
why because of the human nature which is
around negativity bias humans are only
paying attention most of the time to the
negative side of life
those all all of those outlets are
constantly using that negativity bias to
broadcast to you what's actually not the
full truth but the negative side of the
truth
so you know
the the ch a channel will not talk about
a child that went out with his mother
and played on the swings they'll talk
about a child that fell in a well and we
have that disaster and and you know a
social media person i i always say
you're a balanced one but a social media
influencer will
always show this the the pictures that
appear to be more than what they're
living and there will be filters and so
on and that negativity that you feel as
a result is not a reflection of the
actual truth of life
it's a reflection of the subset of
knowledge that you get from life now
what does that mean i mean i'm trying to
say if i give you your phone and your
phone has a perfect phone
app on it
if you type the wrong number you're
going to call the wrong person nothing
wrong with the phone nothing wrong with
the app okay in your brain if you put in
the wrong data all the time if you allow
all of that negativity coming from the
media and the news if you allow the
conditioning to be part of your of your
decision-making criteria the recycled
thoughts and emotions then you're
eventually going to end up calling the
wrong action okay and and i and i think
the reality is that at that very
fundamental level unless you start to
really
iron out all of the wrong inputs
there is very little possibility that
you're actually going to get to the
accurate output
you were talking about all these types
and categories of thoughts and all of
these inputs one of the inputs is the
mainstream media some of the inputs come
from i guess our conditioning and
experiences and when you talked about
the glass and your observation that the
glass is 37
full
how do you know
that that's not your conditioning
speaking how do you know that that's not
the influence of the mainstream media
how do you know that there's not a
second layer that's running over your
what you're seeing called your
perception that is influencing that i'm
trying to figure out for people
listening how they can distinguish
between a thought that is
truth and observation and worth pursuing
and incredible and one that is
conditioned
you're spot-on okay this is 37
full
is my brain's calculation
let's use a simpler example you have an
argument with your partner
the next morning you wake up and say he
doesn't love me or she doesn't love me
anymore right the argument is what you
observed that there was a bit of
attention that those specific words were
said that's observation right
observation is literally like narration
of the situation that's it
and if you can stick down you can take
yourself all the way down to narration
you're done okay i observe that you're
sitting cross hand
you know crossing your arms
i that's an observation my brain could
take that observation and say he's bored
he's protective he is angry with me
we've been talking too much whatever
okay i can translate it into a million
things in my head none of them is true
the only truth is stephen's sitting in
front of me and he's crossing his arms
if i if i accept that to be the truth
then my brain suggests those other
things i can then ask and i say have we
been talking too long steve do you want
should we take a break or can we do this
can we do that right and then you would
say something and that would be my next
observation i can include that in my
analysis as another fact okay without
those facts sadly what happens to us in
life
is that we're completely absorbed and
consumed
by stories
that we've built
the story is
this is 37 full that's a story believe
it or not even so though it appears to
be very accurate
it's a story that includes hey by the
way mo you're good in geography you've
done your mathematics really well you've
looked at those two it looks as if you
and you know it's a big story and i
would tend to tell myself hey it's 37
if i complain complemented this with
you know i think it's for 37 it could be
a little more a little less that's a
much better observation right if i tell
myself the story and believe it
and start acting upon it
then i'm in a very deep
trouble because because basically my
input into my brain is leading me to
confusion certain confusion because i'm
not using the truth
it's that kind of like requirement of
having like a looseness of our beliefs
as well isn't it that just the that old
adage of strong strong beliefs but held
loosely whatever it is that phrases i
think is beautiful thing ever yeah
because because what are your beliefs
your beliefs are built within context
again i write about this you know there
was a proverb in egypt uh that was
developed in the in the times of poverty
and famine people couldn't have enough
and it was a difficult time and it
basically said as far as your
extend your legs as far as your blanket
goes
okay interesting when and you know it's
basically in within context it invites
people to say hey within you live within
your resources live within your means
it's not an easy time
you take that and take it out of context
and it's widely widely used in egypt
when you put it out of context and it
becomes you know a bit of complacency
it's like don't try to buy a bigger
blanket just live within your blanket
okay and that's a very very very
different view of looking at something
that was meant to be correct and if you
take so when i talk about conditioning
you have so many of those in you
so many something that your mom said at
a point in time something that your you
know teacher said at a point in time
something that you did and your friends
in school reacted in a way that you
didn't want and so on and all of that is
embedded within us
again it's very simple it's that
contradiction
it's a very simple contradiction of
something is not in balance i say that i
want a rolls-royce but i actually
go you know go to the rolls-royce and
then feel that
maybe people will think this way about
me maybe uh you know it's gonna cost me
that much maybe right and and and
suddenly you go like okay so i'm not in
balance because what i think we're
talking about here is like really
self-awareness it's becoming really but
also self-reflection self-introspection
and that's that's what i was gonna say
is i think for most of my life
especially because of my conditioning
i'm essentially this puppet to my
conditioning with all these pieces of
string hanging off my limbs and
self-awareness is the process of
gradually cutting one of these strings
at a time and taking back more control
of why i'm doing what i do in my
behavior so that like journaling or
producing content that that
introspection and self-reflection
is has been the cutting of these strings
one by one or you could view it as like
the turning on of lights in a room so
you can kind of navigate better the
world
but until you do that the lights really
are off and i think that's kind of
central to
what we were discussing about how to
distinguish conditioning
media influence from
truth and your own thoughts
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewellery brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery the really wonderful thing
about crafted jewelry is it's super
affordable it looks amazing the pieces
hold tremendous meaning and they are
really well made i think i've worn this
piece for almost a year
it hasn't broken hasn't changed colour
because it's really really good quality
and it costs roughly 50 quid people will
be surprised when they hear that they'll
probably assume that all of my jewelry
is like solid gold and cost thousands
and thousands of pounds but what's the
point when you can achieve the exact
same effect from a piece of jewelry
that's high quality and cost 50 quid
that's why i buy crafted
the other thing that you mention in your
in your book that little voice in your
head is this concept of neuroplasticity
and it says it on the back of the book
it says
um
retrain your brain for maximum happiness
this concept that we can retrain our
brain physiologically seems like
nonsense and i can't change my arm
so when someone you know asserts that
you can
actually change your brain you can
change your arm
i can change my arm of course what
tattoo
no you work out that's true when you
work out you're building muscles in your
arms and that same exact process is
exactly what happens inside our brains
and it's called neuroplasticity the only
difference is that you don't see it you
don't see it visibly you can see your
muscles growing because that's the
function that they need you know they
need to grow to perform but in your
brain what actually happens again like
computers it's almost as if you loaded a
new piece of software i need a new piece
of operating system
on your brain literally for every one of
us listening
uh everyone listening to us right now at
the end of this conversation their brain
will be wired differently than when it
started
every single instance of anything that
you do literally rewires the hardware
itself the neurons that fire together
wire together okay so imagine the old
days of the switchboard okay and
you know
steve wants to call his mom so you
ra you know crank your phone and the
operator says uh you know hi how can i
help you and you say can you please
connect me to that number and she would
literally take a wire and patch you and
your mom's phones together okay after a
while the operator constantly every time
you call you want to you ask for your
mom so the operator goes like why am i
even wasting my time on this let me just
patch that wire to his mom all the time
okay so that's exactly what happens in
our brains if you if you perform a
single a certain function your brain
starts to build networks that make that
function easier to perform in the future
if you do it one time it becomes a
little easier if you do it 20 times it
becomes permanent okay and there are
there are tons of studies if you if you
take a simple task like tapping your
finger on the table okay and you're
requested to do that
say 20 times every hour after a few days
you'll find that you're so much better
at tapping your finger on the table and
you can do it much faster and you can do
it consistently and you can do it in the
background gamers know that for certain
okay the problem with neuroplasticity is
if you tell your brain to wire for
tapping your finger it will
if you tell it to wire for solving
complex mathematical equations it may
take a little longer but it will if you
tell it to wire for hating people it
will become very good at hating if you
tell it to wire for fearing the end of
the world because of what the media is
telling you it's going to become very
good at fearing the world i know some of
those people
no absolutely and you don't want them in
your life the challenge of our modern
world is that we think that this brain
is supposed to be there to make us
successful
yeah
okay first of all it's not the primary
function of the brain the primary
primary function of the brain is to make
you safe
okay and then the secondary function
that we push huma as humans to
that brain to do is to invent iphones
and create podcasts and have amazing
things right that's a secondary function
but believe it or not before that
secondary function your
your brain is supposed to make you happy
because happy is the ultimate form for
you to perform in life if you're not
happy you're not as effective as you
could be at achieving survival
think about it huh if you're grumpy all
the time at work people don't like you
you're not focused uh no one wants to
help you uh you're wasting most of your
time
your brain cycles uh you know thinking
about the negative and so you're not
innovative or creative and so on and so
forth it degrades your performance
happy is a better place for you to be at
work because it will make your customers
want to do business with you it will
make your colleagues want to you know to
help you out it will make your boss
welcome you and their team and so on and
so forth
we are social animals by definition
and we want to have that in our life and
the easiest way to connect and to open
up and to discover the world is to be in
a happy place that's a primary function
of your brain
it's hard for some people you know
because we can all think of someone in
our lives who has um
certain
wiring very stubborn wiring
that almost seems impossible to unwire
and i think we all have that ourselves
as well certain worrying in our brains
where something happens and our reaction
to that thing might be
uh you know to catastrophize it's the
end of the world that's like a it feels
like it's a certain set of worrying
where trigger
and then the brain goes through the
circuitry and it goes catastrophe panic
yeah and and the answer to that i found
was to actually guide that person or
yourself if that's yourself to the
opposite of your wiring so if my if my
wiring is to look at everything and see
what's wrong with it i should
deliberately force my brain to look for
what's right with it
so uh you know i uh when i was when i
was coming here it was very busy in the
morning and so i came late if you
remember and my brain's immediate
reaction is
oh what's going to happen i'm going to
be late for steve right
that's the immediate reaction of a brain
because something is wrong so it looks
for what's wrong
i could also say
and what is good about that what is good
about being a little late you know he's
been recording for the last few days so
it may give him a little bit of extra
time do you want to know the truth i was
so happy you were late because i was
late right so i was doing upstairs
reading that i was reading the book and
i was thinking i just hope he's like 15
minutes late
and then i'm looking at my phone i'm
like
he's not coming at perfect so i carried
on going and carrying on going and
carrying on going and i just finished as
you arrived yeah so it's perfect time
you see that that is the truth that's
the truth that your brain tries to deny
you from seeing and interestingly you
can train your brain so so basically
what you can do is for every thought for
every negative thought that your brain
gives you task it with the task of
giving you a positive one or two
positive ones nine i say nine yeah
because in reality if you look at life
around you more than 90 percent of life
is okay
for your brain to contribute more than
that as negative is not fair
right so if literally if your brain says
hey by the way this studio is a little
warm
what else is about this studio my friend
steve is there the lighting is perfect
the crew is amazing that you know the
coffee is is not that bad you guys get
got me honey i can go on for hours
right and and the idea is by training
your brain to look for that
what are you actually doing you're
firing the neurons together
so and exactly your your book basically
says it is the answer the answer is when
you find gratitude what what the
gratitude journal that you keep ever
that you kept for years every day what
was it telling you
it was training your brain to look for
what's right
that your brain every night that you did
it was like okay it seems he's going to
be asking to call his mom a lot more
often it seems he's going to be asking
for good things a lot more often i might
as well observe them i might as well
find them and so yes
you said some people are impossible to
rewire they're impossible to rewire if
they've been practicing a certain wiring
for 21 years it's not going to take 21
seconds to rewire anyone including me
and you
it will take 21 days let's say for your
brain to recognize i need different
wiring and it will take maybe 20 one
month for your brain to say and i don't
need the old wiring anymore okay and the
game here is can you actually keep doing
that can you keep tapping your finger in
a way that trains your brain that this
is the worrying that you need
like can i keep going to the gym and
working on my absolute guns yeah believe
it or not the research will tell you
that a big part of being athletic is
wiring of your brain not your muscles
for your brain to be able to say i will
go even if i feel a little tired i will
go even if i feel a little uh busy i
will go and i will do the right
exercises even if the last push is a
little
painful a lot of people will hear that
and go what's the evidence for this
what's the evidence for neuroplasticity
is there science oh there is a ton of
science behind neuroplasticity any
anything from between neuroplasticity
and neurogenesis is when
you know neuroplasticity is to rewire um
the connections between the neurons and
neurogenesis is to actually create new
new neurons when if you're hit with a
ball for example and part of your brain
is damaged how we can cr recreate that
right if you have a stroke and how you
create recreate that and
ample evidence one of the very famous
stories is matthew ricard when we spoke
about him in the beginning matthew's
brain
looks different than the average human
brain his insulin is much bigger in
relative comparison his prefrontal
cortex is is bigger and and it fires
more often
it's simply because of the constant
neuroplasticity of i need you to
meditate i need you to stay quiet i need
you i mean
some of the of of
of matthew's journeys would last four
years in isolation he would meditate for
four years
be in isolation in a hermitage for four
years right and and so at that level
your brain starts to do very different
things and by the way that's not unusual
many farmers around the world
live in isolation for a very long time
believe it or not you and i
when we when we spend a long time on
airplanes i i chose a long time ago to
not watch a lot of stuff on on you know
i maybe watch one movie but not the
entire trip the other bits of silence
that's actually a form of of meditation
i uh you know
my my absolute
wonderful friend jamie nelson the
photographer if you know him he
photographs indigenous tribes and the
way he does it is he would go
and uh and spend a few months outside
their premises you know their village if
you want
in silence you know camping out there he
doesn't speak their language he's just
sitting there waiting for them to accept
him and then he would start to you know
communicate to them in sign language
because it doesn't speak their language
and he's one of the wisest people i know
and i and i said how did you become this
wise he never studied any of those
things and the reality is is because
he's in constant reflection and
meditation he's sitting out there
and he's spending hours and days in
reflection and meditation right because
you're sitting alone
all of those things are our habits and
all of us have the chance to do it right
so you you could be on the tube
for a commute of 40 minutes a day and
you could be in that commute cursing
life
and that's a very good 40-minute
exercise to work and another 40-minute
going back or you could be spending the
40 minutes in gratitude you could be
first for you know
spending the 40 minutes listening to
music could be doing whatever
what you will do for 40 minutes a day
will rewire your brain
it really is like a paradigm shifting
thought that our brains are in this
constant growth and evolution but when
we look at as you said my muscles are my
muscles are changing state size
growing more fibers to achieve their
objective in a different way
and of course my brain is as well and
when you think about that it's really
liberating because you realize that
you're not stuck with who you are
absolutely not it's from my friend ro
she's got a podcast as well she um
one of the smartest people i've ever met
and she she worked in my company for
many years and she got a brain tumor
and
she showed me the scan of her brain they
found this golf ball in the middle of
her brain
and they removed it
and she showed me those brain scans and
then
just months later the hole is gone yeah
and her brain has regrown
that part and there's no longer a hole
in her brain and that was one of those
moments when i go oh my god the brain
like like everything
around us is a living organism that is
shaping and evolving based on the inputs
and what's happening to it yeah so let's
choose what's which parts of it are we
going to grow i think that's the whole
point and we grow it with our actions
and our thoughts
repetitive actions thoughts and memories
believe it or not one of the interesting
things is if you take a memory in the
past yeah and you think about it over
and over and over it's as if you're hap
it's happening over and over and you're
growing the neurons that are needed or
you're growing the connections between
the neurons that are needed to trigger
that memory
think happy memories okay if you sit
next to your partner and focus on one
thing that they do and go like they say
do this they do this they do this they
do this and forget that they do a
hundred other things that you you love
and appreciate
your neuroplasticity is making you
completely obsessed about that one thing
and you can only see that one thing and
eventually you know
some of my friends after a breakup i go
like so what happened then they'll say
one thing
it's like just they obsess about it over
and over because your brain is growing
to say he needs to think about this
right i'm going to make it easier to
think about this i'm going to make it
faster
more accessible
and you'll see it more often like the
red cars
you know the old thing about when you
buy like a red car if you buy like a
green car then every car you see will
appear to be green if you're buying
every car you see is a range over well
this other thing that's really
intriguing topic from our last
conversation that you mentioned and you
mentioned in your new book
is this idea of masculinity and
femininity i don't really hear many
people talking about this
yeah believe it or not my my publisher
really was
asking should we include this it's a con
you know con
contested topic do we want to but i
think it's very important for people to
understand
we've mixed up again a few definitions
like i said we mix love and romance for
example with mixed biology
with
gender identity with sexual preferences
with the reality of what the feminine
and the masculine is
the feminine and the masculine in my
definition
are
approaches to life
okay
some basic basically um some people will
want to
hold their mug this way and others will
want to hold it that way it's an
approach to life not no way is right and
no way is wrong okay uh some of us will
want to go through life with creativity
and playfulness and and you know
intuition and some of us will want to go
with
analysis and and
discipline and linear thinking it's an
approach to life neither is right and
neither is wrong
there is a high
correlation
between those who are archetypically
feminine if you want uh
between certain of those qualities
certain some of those qualities and you
know those who are masculine again there
is a correlation
with some other qualities so you would
find that a person who's masculine
whether that's a man or a woman straight
or gay doesn't matter if if a person
acts in their masculine they'll tend to
be a little more
forceful if you think about it you know
we the masculine one of the masculine
qualities is strength okay strength is a
is a quality whether it's strength in
mental strength or physical strength you
wanna you wanna use your strengths to
move things okay
if you're dependent on your masculine
side or more associating with your
masculine side you're gonna show that
and as i said statistically correlated
those who have male body parts tend to
use that a little more
reasoning doesn't matter
the problem with our world
at the global level and the problem at
us
about us
as individuals is we've decided that
some of those properties or qualities
are more valuable to our world than
others
okay if if you live in a capitalist
world and the capitalist world is
entirely about let's produce more let's
make more let's you know
do more we're gonna have to borrow more
from the doing qualities which are
mostly masculine okay
this leads to a world where there is a
lot of doing
with little being which basically means
it's a world where we do a lot of what
we haven't really properly thought about
we've what what is not really informed
by the realities of who we are being
being that beautiful
some of the feminine is being the
feminine is
the masculine does
there is a difference between them and
if you continue to do without actually
asking yourself that awareness question
of what should i do
you end up doing things like building
technologies that make our life slightly
better and destroy the planet in a in in
the process why because you haven't
really internalized some of the most
beautiful feminine qualities of
intuition of creative thinking to look
for alternatives of um um since
sensuality to actually sense
what is actually happening in the world
as a result of your doing of inclusion
you know to connect to the rest of being
to understand that this is not just
about us it's also about the bees and
the and and the bears and everyone else
and so on so that world that we've
created being hyper masculine
is i think the biggest mistake
humanity's ever done and i think
humanity is paying for that mistake and
will pay more in the future the the
savior is for us to stop doing this and
to start waking up and saying hold on
hold on we need a lot of being before
you continue to do
so interesting
it's particularly
tricky to understand for men
of course because men i mean there'll be
a lot of men again you know listening to
this podcast now that hear the idea that
they need to embrace their feminine that
go oh gosh no yeah it will scare them it
will it will appear to um
hurt their identity
theirs their sense of self
um it'll make them feel weaker maybe
it'll make them feel like they're they
have they lack purpose if they're not
that masculine because a lot of a lot of
us as men a lot of our sense of purpose
comes from being competitive from
winning from
being strong apparently that's how it
feels anyway but what is masculine i
mean
if masculine is to protect
for example because we have
the strength
or the masculine has the strength
can that protection happen without
empathy
how can you protect if you don't have
empathy
you need the feminine empathy to be able
to protect
if the masculine is to solve a problem
can you solve the problem without
actually identifying the problem you
need intuition and sensuality and
right if the masculine is about
safety and survival
how can you do that without
living
without uh beauty without uh you know or
art all of that is in the feminine your
comment is right by the way but it is
not because of any difference between
the masculine and the feminine men will
will feel less comfortable with this
because women have been sadly pushed
to live in their masculine to survive in
this hyper-masculine world i i will tell
you honestly and i say that with a
hundred percent uh on you know uh
honesty of that view i thought to myself
that i was intelligent
until four and a half years ago i
started to empower my feminine
and i promise you i'm 10 times more
intelligent i was in my left brain doing
all of the analysis thinking i'm a smart
person
but i was doing all of the analysis with
all of the wrong inputs
the feminine gives you the inputs the
feminine gives you the the picture of
the reality the the inclusion the big
the big view of life you can't see that
with your narrow minded linear brain and
i think the reality is that men who are
most successful
ever in changing the world
believe it or not are more in their
feminine than their masculine anyone has
that has ever changed the world
has been more in their feminine than in
masculine the example i gave when we
spoke about this steve jobs
okay most people think that steve jobs
was an amazing success for ceo because
he was pushy he was you know a bit
obnoxious actually sometimes huh
not at all the reason steve jobs was
steve jobs is because of his feminine
qualities his appreciation of beauty his
appreciation his creativity
his art
his appreciation of color and shape
his empathy to his users needs
all of these are what made steve jobs
that amazing visionary that he was
obnoxious by the way pulled it back a
little bit
gandhi even though sometimes gandhi is
contested but gandhi's success
is not in saving his nation through the
masculine qualities if it was the
masculine qualities he would have
rallied a billion people to kill the
brits no he went into a a peaceful
non-violent uh a a an empathy an attempt
to make things work through
communication all of these are feminine
qualities and somehow we forget in our
narrow-minded
hyper-masculine world because we've
narrowed everything to dollar signs
so productivity and profit and all of
those dollar signs
and so if that's the target yes doing
more producing more selling more is a
good is a good way to go but the reality
is anyone who's ever made the world
better
not richer
did it by living in their feminine first
how does one tap into their feminine
side because i think it's important to
also say because these words have been
associated with genders for so long but
a woman or someone that's trans can also
be too much in their masculine side
absolutely and vice versa a man or
someone that's trans identifies as
whatever gender can also be too much in
their feminine side but so how does
someone tap in
more to their feminine self
is there an activity is it just a choice
we make is
so so i i think it first requires an
exercise of awareness so and actually
in in that little voice in your head in
in that chapter specifically i have
quite a few awareness exercises okay
those awareness exercises start by
recognizing what's the feminine
and that's a beautiful exercise a
beautiful exercise that you can actually
experience if you
invited a couple of friends over uh that
are
you know feminine in their
actions most of the time and a couple of
friends that are masculine interactions
all of the time and allah an allocated
proper time for each of them to solve a
problem
okay and observe the behavior you will
find
incredible differences between
the masculine side man or woman it
doesn't matter which will jump in and
say okay we're going to carry this and
then take it 10 steps away from here and
then we're going to do this and lift it
on the shelf right away
okay when the feminine will say things
like um
i i feel that this might be a little
heavier for john than it is for jack and
i sense that if we can collaborate
around it as one being we can do this
slightly differently okay so sometimes
they'll say
things like why do we have to do this at
all
isn't there a bigger world where maybe
we could uh just keep it here okay and
and and by that observation you'll start
to to to identify the the qualities
that's that's number one number two is
what i call the appreciation exercise
the appreciation cri exercises to flip
rules okay is to sit in front of you and
say uh
steve
how would you solve that problem
and then wait and then tell you how
would you solve it if you were jackie
okay and that appreciation exercise
basically starts to get you to say oh my
god there is another way and that other
way is not really me it's jackie's way
but it's interesting okay and then the
third is practice practice practice
practice i i tell you openly i've been
empowering my feminine for the last four
and a half years okay now probably five
years and my biggest exercise for the
last two years has been an exercise of
flow we spoke about that at the
beginning the idea of flow is the is the
is the truth of the feminine the
feminine is life itself
it's flowing it's gushing across life
across the world across territories
across uh uh you know times and stories
and and we if we live in our masculine
we go like nope
not going there this is not my place
this is my place i'm going there and i i
liken it always with a river a raging
white water river
if you put the masculine in the boat the
masculine will take will take the the
you know the water then push it because
they want to go there they want to be
right there
the feminine will just hold the arms and
and basically say okay the river is
going i just need to balance it every
now and then with one
one strike just to stay in and on track
but it's okay to take a little longer
with the river to get to where i want to
be
and and that massive difference
i'm sorry to say and i'm you know
someone who associated with the
masculine for a very long time is stupid
honestly stupid because suddenly somehow
you realize that life itself is talking
to you through your family life itself
is saying let go i'm i'll do things
okay i'm much more
powerful mighty wheels i can do stuff
just let go a little just flow with me a
little and if you manage to do that i
chose flow i i think there are you know
several other major pillars of the
feminine one of them is inclusion as i
say so so relating to others choose that
if you want to one of them is temporal
okay the masculine is very linear we
associate with the arrow of time where
the feminine is very rhythmic we
associate with cycles okay and so if you
can actually see the difference between
them that's a very interesting exercise
um you know i i think creativity and
playfulness uh and breaking the rules
sort of i think paradoxical thinking i
do to me these are the big five pillars
paradoxical thinking is to in is to be
able to be humbled enough to embrace
that two opposing stories are true
two opposing facts can actually exist
together interesting
and the role of the masculine
amazing the role of the masculine energy
so so that's a beautiful question so the
problem we had with the movement of
feminism and i say that with love and
respect is that it demonized the
masculine
now what needs to be demonized is
overdoing the masculine
okay so you know strength is good that
is me sometimes by the way i have to
admit
i definitely overdo the masculinity my
girlfriend tells me as well she goes
she'll literally say it like that though
because she's very
in touch with her feminine masculine and
she'll say you're being you know
you're being too in the masculine right
now yeah you know what's one of the most
yeah one of the most common
uh um things i'm told by a woman who's
uncomfortable with how her boyfriend is
behaving is he's unable to
be available emotionally yeah of course
we we suffer from that that's a
consequence of toxic absolutely
so let's talk about this concept because
it's very important huh there is no
demonizing of a quality linear thinking
is a wonderful quality okay if you can
think about a problem linearly
that's a wonderful quality over doing it
makes you stubborn
do you understand it's the overdoing
that's the problem
it's strength wonderful you overdue
strength you become violent we don't we
don't want the overdoing and what's what
should be demonized is over doing that
it's overdoing anything including by the
way overdoing the feminine so you know
if if you're
intuitive it's a wonderful quality
but if you're uh if you're too much into
intuition you're ignoring linear facts
and analysis
if you're um let's say paradoxical my
one of my favorite as i always say if
you can if you can embrace paradoxes
it's a wonderful quality it gives you a
double the amount of information to
analyze if you want to do analytical
thinking
but if you overdo it you become a little
irrational right if you're disciplined
as a masculine quality
or not discipline at discipline at all
you become irrational so overdoing
something
or underdoing something
is not good for any of us
what is the right amount of doing
something by the way
it's how you are configured
so i am much more empathetic
and maybe creative
and maybe playful
than i am paradoxical
okay uh i am much more uh in uh you know
in linear con
thinking and control than i am in um uh
you know flow this is why i work on my
flow believe it or not through
neuroplasticity so what i'm doing with
my life now for the last two years is
i'm living a life of flow i'm allowing
life to tell me what to do and instead
of my hyper-engineered mathematical
brain saying nope
that's not the way it should be done
i've done my analysis it's 37 i'm gonna
do this okay i i start to listen and say
hey
i'm gonna make the decision if it's 37
or not in a couple of weeks time
no harm done if i was wrong but
intuition is beautiful
it's hard to
uncondition oneself but it goes back to
this point about we were rewiring our
brains by repetition
and you know when i think about
being more in my feminine energy and my
feminine qualities and characteristics
it is a
it is achieved by repetition
by
um being opening up to that side of me
and spending more time
wiring my myself
to in that way which i think is so
important it's funny because i know
there'll be a lot of people listening to
this that either don't understand or
have kind of misunderstood because we're
using terms that come with like stigma
when we think of femininity or when we
think of masculinity there's there's
connotations with that but
it's um so unbelievably true and if
people have listened to this podcast
they would they'll know it's true from
you know we had terry crews on here who
talked about his masculinity and how
that became
incredibly harmful to him and
destructive and risked his relationships
and his and everything that mattered to
him we had patrice evra talk about how
early experiences that made him
lean towards masculinity to help him
survive being abused by his head teacher
and watching his brothers and sisters
die because of drug addiction on the
streets of france made him turn more to
that masculinity as a tool for survival
but then it but then that cost him so
dearly but because he lived out of
balance to one day sat with his partner
she said there's something not right
with you there's something not right
with you he resisted he resisted he
resisted then boom burst into tears
and that's the moment where he opened up
yeah
you see it you see it then you know it
but and by the way i think i think in
reality
what i'm asking for
is now that the world has finally
accepted gender diversity and fluidity
and so on
i'm asking us not to be more categorized
okay i'm asking us to stop saying so i'm
category a category b category category
d because we've just moved from man
woman to more categories now i'm asking
us to say that mo
is unlike anyone else in his mix of
masculinity and femininity i'm 58
okay in certain qualities of the
feminine are more than others and you
could be 42 percent and in other
qualities of the feminine and not more
than others and i think the idea is to
say each and every one of us is an
individual each and every one of us is a
category of their own okay everyone the
only category i fit in
is i'm a mo that's it that's my category
and that category includes a beautiful
blend of qualities that i can use that
are not any better or any worse than
anyone else okay those qualities that i
blend together might be amazing for this
podcast conversation but horrible at
[ __ ] making pizza i don't know right and
i think the reality is if you can become
true to that reality of who you are
you'll become the best at that that
you're supposed to do in life
and without that balance you will always
always feel incomplete
now you've written what is another
legendary book on a very
related but
incredibly foundational topic which is
our thoughts and that little voice in
our heads
and um
i think if this conversation is a flavor
of the book than it is
i think in everyone's view that's
listening a must read you know it's
funny that we i talk about time being
the single currency that we can allocate
to determine the outcomes of our lives
but
thoughts are
the interesting they're the thing that
is determining how we spend that
currency yeah i think i think time is
the rhythm of your song the song of your
life
and thoughts really are the lyrics that
you put on top of it they are the melody
they are
they are as as we spend a minute of our
life thinking a certain thought
that minute completely shapes
how the song of your life is going to be
it's quite interesting how we ignore
that and so maybe
maybe thoughts are the most important
thing and what this book does is it
helps us to adjust
the code that runs our brains
at the last line in your book um
you say i have one last selfish request
please find the compassion in your heart
to want happiness for my wonderful son
ali
and wise teacher
send him a prayer a generous wish that
he is happy wherever he is right now he
started it all and he truly was the
kindest happiest human i have ever known
i'll keep working on mine for ali
why did you bring that up we were having
an easy conversation
yeah
so um
yeah i wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
what he taught me and i wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for the example he said and
i wouldn't be here if it hadn't been for
him
leaving us
and um
and i uh
it's interesting that
i told i may have told you this once
before that
i write the last sentence of every book
before i write the rest of the book
yeah and i i have to say i have been
blessed with so many people that send me
messages that say i love ali
and
yeah i feel that
if it was
that only that that i got from the work
i've done then i've lived it's there's
nothing worse more and and and but i'm
getting so much more i'm getting so much
um
purpose if you want
but i don't want to be forgetting him in
that purpose i think that's where i
stand today that i'm so driven but by
what i'm trying to achieve
and he's been
away for seven years almost eight years
now
so i once again need him to be part of
our journey so
so yes please send him happy wish
the work he's done through you is truly
magical through you is the exact right
word
it's funny when when we spoke about
the idea of control being a masculine
quality
only when i let go
only when i let go that
life whether
with him or through him or maybe he's
the boss i have no idea but
what i've what i've accomplished was so
much more than what i did when i was
trying to control everything
and it's because of how he showed me to
do to do with
as you know we have a closing tradition
on this podcast oh i should have
prepared for that
oh my god i didn't think about this
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
sometimes you know a lack of preparation
leads to the best outcomes
okay
question is
ooh
that's not encouraging steve oh so i
really like this question it's very
fitting i think
the previous guest wrote for
you what is the greatest wealth in your
life
what was not the greatest wealth was all
of the money all of the cars all of the
uh
things
it was a waste of life i promise you and
i know most people will say yeah you you
say that because you had it when you
have it too you will feel the same it
was a total waste of life
uh when you wrote in your book
that we come to this life
with 500 000 chips you say you remember
you wrote 80 hour eight if you live 80
years you will have 500 000 hours of
active life or something like that
and that this is your wealth
this is what you come to the to the
world with and you place those chips
hour hour by hour the thought that came
to my head was i was born a millionaire
500 000 hours is a lot of hours
but then you turn you take that cash and
you turn it to equity it's really
interesting how you take those hours
and by placing those chips
you turn one chip
into equity into something that lasts
and and the things that i know last are
experiences
knowledge and love
and i promise you we will never acquire
anything more important than any of
those three
in in an interesting order actually they
are love
knowledge and experiences so so what we
what we
what we go through in all of our life is
we
do
tons of things
that we think are gonna acquire us
uh one of those three
you know unhappiness of course
but but
in reality it's so much easier to
acquire those three directly the biggest
wealth you will ever have
are
a set of experiences that can't be
repeated
some knowledge that can be beneficial
for yourself and those around you
and uh the feeling of love
which i have been overwhelmed with
i mean i can tell you i'm the richest
man i know by far from the number
of kind messages that i get from people
saying
you know we love what you do we
appreciate your your attempt to make the
world better
that love i think is the biggest wealth
i have ever acquired and i always say
alien i am my daughter
definitely have been the biggest love of
my life for sure and
when ali left to take that life away
i feel that the fairness of life
replaced it with the li with the love of
hundreds of thousands of people
which interestingly i'm so grateful for
but it's almost exactly barely enough
to balance the love that i have for him
and so yeah maybe maybe we should spend
our life acquiring more of these
thank you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast for many years
people have been asking for a coffee
flavored huel and quite recently he'll
release the iced coffee caramel flavor
of their um ready to drink heels and
i've just become hooked on it over the
last couple of weeks and now i'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors the caramel flavor is amazing
the new banana flavor as well is amazing
and obviously as i said the iced coffee
caramel flavor has been a real smash
here so check it out let me know what
you think on social media i see all of
your tags and instagram posts and tweets
about you back to the podcast
um
[Music]
[Music]
you